the chapter that I've asked you to read
for this week deals with the Industrial
Revolution it is kind of an antique in
the sense that the term Industrial
Revolution is losing its its cachet
excuse me I will turn this er
conditioner off sound is too much
when I look at other textbooks I find
that some of them use the term but they
do not have a chapter using the term the
title there's one that uses the term
Industrial Revolution and also
industrious revolution to say that well
this is when people became heavily
occupied with new businesses and
manufacturers and so forth but they were
not you know but Industrial does not
pertain to that so what what is the
problem here
I think part of the problem is that the
United States
and in many parts of Europe are
post-industrial when the term Industrial
Revolution was in in stronger favor
there was a notion that you could define
the world as industrialized or
non-industrialized that you we had books
that would I remember a book in
particular by uh and then shoberg who
talked about the title of the book was
the pre industrial city where you would
define what an industrial city was like
and then you see whether all cities that
were not industrial had common features
everywhere in the world or you talk
about industrializing countries or
pre-industrial countries but the
assumption always was that to be
industrialized to be an industrial
society that was the top of the heap as
opposed to be to being a society that
was at the cutting edge of financial
services so that when you have a country
like the United States where
manufacturing has fallen dramatically
and financial services and other service
occupations have become the main stays
of the economy then you're a little less
inclined to say well industry is the the
be-all and end-all of human achievement
because industry if it's now being
pursued proportionally more in China and
India and Brazil and Turkey and other
industrializing societies well it may be
that we had kind of a premature
round of thinking when we were talking
about industrialization being
revolutionary so now you have people who
would say well is it right to call it a
revolution and of course you can chew on
a term like that all day long and you
know it's like a old piece of gum you
pretty quickly get less and less and
nourishment out of it when did the term
come and do in new parlance I found one
source that said that it was coined by
arnold toynbee which would put it in the
interwar period of the 20th century
another source that says that it was a
term used in the 1830s in Britain
another one saying that it's a 19th
century French term so I'm not sure that
you can find a specific individual who
coined the term industrial revolution
but it certainly caught on so the notion
of an industrial revolution becomes a
commonplace and it's usually twinned
with the french revolution as being that
period of revolutionary change the
scientific revolution is considered to
be somewhat earlier more in the 17th
century than in the 18th century there
are phrases like the Second Industrial
Revolution tree fruit to refer to
industries that arise in the late 20th
century so there are various bells and
whistles that are put on this idea of
Industrial Revolution but I think
there's no mistaking the the fact that
there was a time when when
industrialization was seen as the as I
say as the be-all and end-all of human
achievement in the mid 19th century
there was a reference book published a
one-volume encyclopedia called parlays
panorama and curiosities with nature it
was published in Cincinnati I believe
and was a book that sold well to farm
families in the Midwest as the
repository of all knowledge and it is
example of of the the idea that you
could have all the knowledge that we
need to know an encyclopedic form
sitting there in one volume in your in
your parlor what the Columbia
encyclopedia became in the 20th century
when that still had a print version
parlays panorama has a a coda at the end
entitled wonders of half a century
talking about the period 1800 1850 Steve
that Steam Navigation canals macadam
eyes drones railroads electric
telegraphy balloon steaming may we not
soon add have their entire history
within the 19th century - it also
belongs besides many other discoveries
and inventions photography guncotton
gutta-percha the preparation of various
abundant but before unknown esculent for
food homeopathy hydropathy teaching of
the blind death and deaf and dumb' cure
of the insane association association .
i have no idea what that means
ah
where am i there
skip a little bit
Millions Oh si steam and electricity
relieve the weary muscles of the toiling
millions from Hercule Herculean Labor's
and send them after a fair day's work in
two comfortable homes with time and
means to cultivate their better natures
and taste the sweets of intellectual and
nor and
moral education freed by science from
the delays of warm of wind and tide and
the thousand obstacles which beset their
path commerce hastens across the
harmless seas or the level pathways of
iron to pour plenty into every lap the
Reformation and consequent increase of
intelligence among the masses had given
a more thorough understanding of the
practical principles of the Christian
religion to the millions who had
hitherto allowed others to do most of
their Christianity for them as a
necessary consequence of this increased
intelligence the sympathies of the
masses were enlarged this is kind of
your capsule story of the progress of of
Europe the Reformation comes it changes
the moral outlook it brings Christianity
into a practical relationship to the
real world things are invented
discoveries are made and you have a kind
of Nirvana that is achieved through
through this process which is already
there by 1850 presumably if the term
Industrial Revolution had in fact become
known by the 1830s presumably this was
the frame of mind that led people to
think of these incredible achievements
as being revolutionary and of course one
of the problems with with today's
revolution is that it might not seem so
revolutionary tomorrow so what we have
in the chapter that I've asked you to
read is a pretty extensive
account of the Industrial Revolution the
early Industrial Revolution with
specific examples of specific industries
and explaining what happened and
contributing to the seemingly the the
message of the book that there was
something special and dramatic that
occurred in Europe and particularly in
England in the late 18th and early 19th
centuries that led to a revolutionary
changes that are unparalleled elsewhere
this argument for an industrial
revolution has been profoundly
challenged by world historians the great
divergence by Kenneth Pomerance is
devoted entirely to demonstrating that
Europe and China really were not very
different at that time that if you look
at levels of pay levels of nutrition
levels of rates of innovation and so
forth that China was on a par with
Europe or on a near par and that to the
degree that there is some substance
behind the notion that Europe came out
way ahead it is a consequence of
Europe's extracting both wealth and
goods from the new world so for example
if he talks about English manufacturing
Pomerance we'll talk about how if you
have goods that are produced but
agriculture does not grow so that you
have manufactured goods but more and
more food has to be imported because you
can't you'll be
the productivity the notion of
productivity per person cannot be viewed
simply in terms of a single you know a
single industry you have to look at what
is the productivity of the population
across the board are they growing having
a harder time keeping up with a growing
population with food whereas in China
they're they're keeping up well how does
that balance out things like like
industry he points out that the so much
of the story of the Industrial
Revolution relates to to the growth of
the of the cotton industry in Britain
that you have changes in spinning of
thread and weaving of cloth and so on
that lead to the great to great cotton
mills in places like Manchester and that
this is a revolutionary change and
that's the usual story but then he will
balance that it'll say that is true that
there were huge changes in cotton
manufacturing but the fees did not apply
to wool and linen and England did not
grow any cotton so that as long as
England had to import all of the cotton
for its Mills you had where as it could
grow flax domestically and it could pass
your sheep and get wool domestically was
this so much a huge step forward or
simply a step that was making England
more and more dependent upon a colonial
upon colonial possessions particularly
in the United States and then during the
American Civil War when the cotton
industry was
risks being crippled because of the cut
off and exports from the American South
that was the period of the great boom in
Egyptian cotton because the the mills
required it so then there's question did
people want to wear cotton or did they
want to wear linen or do they want to
wear wool cotton manufactured cotton
became comparatively cheap but for a
long time it was not dramatically
cheaper than or of higher quality than
fabricated cotton cloth that could be
brought in from India or or other places
so how important was cotton why is that
singled out the thing about because it's
it's such a clear-cut case and yet often
only point out that the cotton mills
were run by steam engines
well actually a very large proportion of
the cotton mills were run by water power
there is a peculiar emphasis put on
steam power that seems to have
captivated 19th century thinkers more
than anything else at the that steam
with at the heart of the Industrial
Revolution steam generated by burning
coal which was fairly easily mined in in
Britain but when you look at the
question of steam power in places where
coal was easily mined and easily
accessed then you might find steam
ultimately being used for manufacturing
but in many other areas
it was the there was water power
virtually every city in Europe
of any significance was on a body of
water a flowing water of some sort that
can be used to generate generate power
the stories of industrial revolution
really don't talk much about water power
that appears to be a something that's
becoming obsolete steam is coming in
what could steam do that water power
could not do well initially what it
could do was be located somewhere else
in fundamentally what you have whether
you have a wheel that is turned by
flowing water or whether you have a
wheel that is turned by by the force of
steam you are turning rotational energy
into some other kind of energy either
reciprocal energy going back and forth
or gearing it down so we use gears you
use belts that connect pulleys and
wheels and so forth the the question of
how you hook your machinery up is pretty
much the same whether the source of the
energy is steam or water and there isn't
much innovation in that but you you have
to have a lot yet you have a larger and
larger scale that is undertaken if you
go say to New England a place like
Lowell Massachusetts and you look at the
old cotton mills that they have there
they're now turned into condominiums and
local history museums things like that
they're all sitting there right on the
river you know if they're using steam
power there was no reason to to situate
them on riverfront riverfront property
what you could do is steam however was
put it on a wheeled platform
and have the the power of the steam
being used to propel that platform and
that's becomes the railroad so I
mentioned before the precursor the
railroad is the carriage so that the
notion of a four wheeled platform and
you could put a steam engine on with all
of the things involving inventions like
brakes and suspension and steering those
were all there before the steam engine
came along and as it turned out the
steam engine could be used very well for
railroads less well for anything else
one of the few things that it seems to
have been successful at was the steam
roller where you would even when you
were building your roads and you needed
to have your Road flattened a steam
roller was of such weight that had to
have a steam engine that would push it
slowly ahead to crush and level a
surface that was a good thing for steam
but if you wanted to use it for a for
something would go faster you had the
problem that the engine itself was very
extremely heavy for a steam engine
that's fine because you're looking for a
lot of weight but but for steam tractors
or steam cars by a large steam was not
very adaptable to to anything but but
railroads although there you had a huge
increase particularly in Europe because
that is where the the template of the of
the
railroad car was already already in
existence then you could put a steam in
a boat and you could have a steamship
that was perhaps the most important use
of steam because what it was replacing
could not easily be replaced by anything
else at that time steamboats were a
revolutionary innovation and they spread
around of the world fairly rapidly
but you you generate steam you can use
your steam for various purposes but if
you compare the advent of steam to let
us say the advent of electricity or of
transmissible electricity alternating
current the number of things that you
end up being able to to do with
electricity is vastly greater than the
number of things that you're able to do
to do with steam one way to to look at
this is to think well what would it be
like if those things that we associate
with our contemporary world have been
thought of and exploited back when you
had steam in but before you have
electricity and this is at the heart of
a genre of counterfactual fantasy or
science fiction works called called
steampunk where you imagine what it
would have been like to have kind of a
world that we look at as being modern
occurring in the steam age the most
interesting of those books that I'm
aware of is one by
two important cyberpunk authors William
Gibson and Bruce Sterling called the
difference engine and they look back at
the early 19th century work by Charles
Babbage to invent what we would call a
computer and it never was brought to
fruition and what they imagined is that
the computer that is to say a automated
way of manipulating digitized
information they try and imagine what
would have been like if the computer had
come into existence in the 1820s instead
of after World War two and so of course
they have computers but they operate
with a great deal of noise because
they're continually they're depending on
Steam for their power so you have you
only like your screen will be made up of
physical objects that will keep turning
into very it like on one side will be
dark want to be light say for a black
and white screen and then your your
steam power will determine what the
pattern of white and black will be so
you can transmit information this way
and they visualize a an information
transformation of society going back to
the 19th century and you read it and you
realize well what a preposterous idea
that is because it would have been just
unbelievably difficult to have to have
made that happen you would have you know
thousands of moving parts for everything
one or a thousand of which are going to
malfunction every few seconds it's
simply impossible but this is one of the
problems with the whole the whole
visualization of this is that
things came about that nobody had
visualized and that were seen as
transformative and that people then
extrapolated and said well if we have
gone this far well then surely we're on
the way to something dramatically more
like we have a revolution that isn't
simply something new but the threshold
of something that will be continuously
new from now on the in probably's
panorama there the conjecture of a
future when you'll have balloons
steaming they have balloons they have
steam engines put a balloon in a steam
engine then you can have balloons
steaming so long as you have and have
like you mungus amount of hydrogen to
lift a steam engine off the ground
because of course it's extremely heavy
so there appears to been a and it's
intense more anticipation than then
substance and the question of my mind is
where where does this sort of
anticipation come from why did these new
things come about when they did some
things that came about that we find
extraordinarily modern could have come
about 500 years or a thousand years
earlier if you if you take a stick and
you would you attach to the to the end
of the stick for things like veins
coming out of our feathers coming out of
an arrow in other words you have for you
know square items that stick out and
90-degree angles to one another and if
you draw on each of those things that
stick out a picture of of someone or
some thing moving
and you show the stages of that motion
if you rotate it in front of your face
you see the effect of motion it's the
closest thing we have now was a flipbook
which of course could have been made at
any time in history as long as you had
paper for example we have evidence
textual evidence that that the notion of
motion that could be seen that way was
there in Roman times that people - oh
here's something you can do and see it
looks like it moves the origin of motion
pictures in the 19th century that's
where it starts it didn't require steam
it didn't require coal it didn't require
steel it didn't require electricity what
it required was drawing pictures in a
sequence that would show motion putting
them on let's say on the inside of a
large diameter cylinder and having a
aperture that you look through and then
turning it with a crank now
nothing no sophisticated invention
required other than thinking to do it
and people did that they would say okay
I can now show you a motion picture and
you know you can just turn this crank
and you will see a picture to move I
know it works because when I taught a
seminar in history of Technology one of
the students built one brought into
class look look through here Oh
motion pictures
why would anyone want to see a picture
move
it will be a novelty but the idea that
you would take that novelty and then
think expansively about where you might
go with it that's what seems to be
involved in so much of this 19th century
development the the enthusiasm for the
new the sense that we are living or they
were living then in an age of
extraordinary invention someone in that
period developed the idea of a straddle
bicycle a two-wheeled thing with a
saddle with your feet touching the
ground on either side if you wanted to
put them down no pedals no gears but
kind of like say a large form of a oh a
razor scooter or a you know skateboard
way the way you could move faster on a
level surface we have pictures we know
that this was done it didn't take off
but it was a sort of thing people were
thinking of they they came up with new
things if you have people who are living
in that period and where new things are
being in being brought into being and
being celebrated why did it happen then
and not earlier in as much as the most
of the things that come into being in
addition to steam engines and steamboats
don't require a technological
breakthrough
I'm sorry stressing this because
the tendency among historians is to say
this is all derived from the history of
science and that you had you know Oxford
and Cambridge graduates who would
experiment with scientific things they
would discover laws of nature and lo and
behold only 150 years later you would
have some result of this but I think
that to some degree this this
concentration on what scientists do is
is unwarranted
it isn't thinking up something have to
be at the beginning it's it's turning it
into a useful application that will then
spread and become a basis for an
industry Charles Darwin's grandfather
thought of the idea that if you have a
carriage and at the front wheels of the
carriage when you want the parish to
turn normally you would turn the axle
pivot the axle he he thought
supposing you pivoted the wheels at
either end of the axle then you would
have more stability and it would be just
a better way of steering so he he had
one made for himself and that was
carriage he used say look my carriage
steers differently from your carriage oh
no interesting but there was no industry
sixty years later or so somebody else
came up with the idea and it turned into
the basis for the steering systems we
have in automobiles today having the
idea did not lead inexorably to
to making the idea workable whether it
was a question of scaling it up or
increasing the volume of production or
finding more efficient ways to do it
whatever it was
probably most of the ideas that they
came along at that time never never made
it so what determines whether ideas will
prosper or or not right now if you read
certain people who bring their hands
about the American economy they're
continually saying well where will the
next Steve Jobs come from you know what
will be our new industries are we
preparing our students sufficiently to
invent those new things that will bring
back our industrial might and our
dominance in the world or are we simply
letting all of our best minds go into
financial services and we're losing
headway to people elsewhere in the world
and nobody seems to have a particular
idea about how how this process of
innovation works now the way it would
work today presumably is not the same as
it would have been in 1700 I don't mean
to say that there's some sort of
clear-cut answer but clearly there has
to be some something that makes new
ideas significant and it's not obvious
what it is nor is it obvious that it's
the same thing all the time
in studying the parallel commercial
developments in China it seems that many
of the the wealthiest industrialists in
China in this period say the early Ching
dynasty after 1600 let's say by 1800
many of the wealthiest industrialists in
China are people who who own and operate
salt wells in western China in such wan
province a salt well is a whole board
down through stone a down to twenty five
to twenty five hundred to three thousand
feet until it hits a layer of a brine
water that is though thirteen or
fourteen percent salt you bore this
whole down and it may take several years
to bore the whole and clearly there's a
real premium on the people who have the
skill or the sense of where you where
such a whole might be successful in the
way you would have now with the
petroleum industry so take a long time
to bore the hole down but then once you
board it down you you have a chamber you
lower it with the rope when it gets down
to the level of the brine that it sinks
down into the into the salty water
there's a leather valve in the bottom
the chamber fills up with the water and
then when you start to pull it up the
valve closes so you bring it to the top
and now you have a chamber full of salt
water and you empty it into a vat you
put the thing down again in other words
no no extraordinary technology
nothing like steam or something like
that but an enormous amount of
of enterprise devoted to to making it
happen
someone was it was labor-intensive both
to bore the whole and to extract the
brine it was capital intensive and that
you had to pay that labor for a long
period of time before the hole was
completed and you didn't know until you
got there whether you were going to get
brined at the end or not but in western
China this was an important industry and
those industrialists became no key
elements of the growth of industry in
China my colleague Madeline's Ellen has
written a book on this called early the
merchants of Geelong where does the
details about this other scholars have
looked at Japan they said well where did
the industrialists come from there it
turns out a significant number of them
start out brewing sake
they are Brewers that is not a science
that requires some sort of great
scientific breakthrough although I
suppose some sake is better than other
sake and maybe some one have special
recipes that work better than others but
this is where you had the accumulation
of money that led to some of the biggest
industrial fortunes in China so what
when you might guess that is that the
people who make it happen if that's the
crucial element those are people who are
you know probably not themselves
scientists may not themselves be people
with advanced education but they're
people who get their hands dirty
they're people who know how a process
operates
and they know it not simply by being an
owner who has workers who are socially
disconnected from the owner at a very
profound level but but the
industrialists themselves know how to do
these things and to improve techniques
and gradually acquire money and then
when they acquire money what do you do
when you acquire money if you acquire it
from this sort of thing from an
industrial process can you become a
Confucian gentleman well maybe your son
can be you get him to study the classics
and sit for the examination but you know
maybe that's not your goal can you take
the son of a brewer of sake and have him
become a samurai or a dino a of feudal
lord in Japan well probably not so in
Europe can a someone who is an
industrialists use that industry to
become a nobleman to become a Duke or an
earl or a major estate holder in the
20th century yes you can be a beer lord
you have the huge brewery and so you get
on the on the Queen's list and you get
neither does you know sir Budweiser st.
Louis or whatever and but you go back to
period we're talking about
say you 1750 in 1815 and you it was very
hard to rise in social rank in a well
stratified traditional European society
what you could do is simply expand your
hold and what you were doing in other
words you could have so many spindles
that were spinning cotton thread and you
could multiply that and now you have
instead of a thousand spindles you have
ten thousand spindles and then you have
twenty thousand spindles you're
producing more and more and more and
more cotton thread and you're selling
that thread so you're becoming richer
and richer and richer but the social
stratification is is against you when it
comes to trading in that kind of that
wealth for a change in social State some
people could do it some do that well
would you want to spend your time and
effort increasing the number of spindles
that were under your control that to me
this is a very puzzling thing when you
look at the at the non noble population
in Europe the commoner population you
can divide it into people who work in
the fields and that would be your your
largest population people who who work
with their hands
your artisan population and people who
who work in buying and selling your
retail and banking population we tend to
celebrate you know the bankers and to
talk about how from the 1600 on the
existence of joint stock companies made
it possible for people to invest in
enterprises that would pay them a
dividend and their money could multiply
as a result of this investment that was
certainly true
but a lot of that investment was in was
in trade and by trade here I I mean both
internal trade your buying and selling
with any society but also foreign trade
so the earliest joint stock companies
like the Dutch East India Company the
English eight East Indian company or the
English Moscow Company or Virginia
Company places like that Massachusetts
Bay Company a lot of these were
enterprises that expected to to buy
goods abroad bring them back to Britain
and sell them or buy or produce goods
abroad using the labor that had abroad
sell them somewhere else and ultimately
repatriate the profits the shareholders
in Europe but the the shareholders were
not generally people who got their hands
dirty they weren't some of them may have
gone as gentleman merchants who would go
abroad and seek their fortunes but many
of the investors would simply be people
who invested and hope to get a profit
out of it and were not themselves the
ones that made things happen if you look
at the farming population their capacity
to make things happen beyond their daily
grind was very limited if you look at
the artisan population now here you have
something somewhat different you have
artisans who specialized in producing a
certain thing a shoe or a or a saddle or
you know a jar of a cheese or something
like that then you have artisans whose
work is related to the work of other
people that they are facilitators of of
commercial activity as well as people
doing it themselves the most evident
people in this category for the for this
period of late 18th and early 19th
century would be those people who who
work with with fire particularly Smith's
various kinds but also potters people
who know the who know from from personal
experience how you indicate how you know
how hot an oven is how you make it
hotter how you you know how much coal or
wood you need to stoke that fire how you
design the kill or the oven in which the
fire will carry out its activity in your
producing products from horseshoes to
you know to jug water jugs that people
utilize but you're also acquiring a
particular expertise that is going to
prove transferable to larger industries
metal industries in the course the
Industrial Revolution particularly the
steel industry then you have the people
who work with with power and those are
notably people who operate windmills and
water mills a windmill or a water mill
would turn a stone or turn a shaft and
that stone could grind grain that is
where the mills began but that stone
could also be geared to a saw so you
have a sawmill could be geared to a
hammer a trip hammer so pound paper pulp
for example so you have a paper mill
if he it could be geared to various
things to carry out some industrial
process that otherwise we done by hand
the Millers were assisted when they
first become prominent between say ten
hundred and thirteen hundred they're
assisted by requirements that come to be
written into aristocratic relations with
Circe that required that that the
residence of an estate bring their grain
to the mill to be ground instead of
grinding it themselves at home
this meant that you had the landowner
who was in a position to impose
requirements on his farmers was helping
the Miller he was bringing business to
the mill and he would often be also
helping the Miller to to provide the
money to build the mill in the first
place because it was a very expensive
thing to build a mill so you end up with
Miller's and Smith's sort of standing
out among that of that straight of a
population between the the bankers and
the and the trade of trade merchants and
the farmers I mean that artisan middle
ground
it's the Millers and the Smiths that
that stand out
I would argue that this stratum was
terribly important in providing the the
social milieu in which the Industrial
Revolution could take place or in which
the changes that we label Industrial
Revolution could take place they knew
how processes worked they accumulated a
great deal of money if they were
successful they were not likely to rise
into upper social ranks and they tended
to be distributed around the countryside
say unlike the bankers and the and the
large commercial traders who bought and
sold who would be primarily in cities or
in seaports you had Miller's all over
the place in the countryside and you had
Smith's all over the place than in the
countryside fire and water are the
really the key elements here one
indication of this is how important
these occupations came as indicated by
people adopting them as their as their
surnames you know if you were well you
know my name is you know Frank the
garbage collector you didn't pass that
name on to your kids you know we don't
have any surname garbage collector or or
industrial or farm laborer or something
like that
but we have a fair number of names that
come from the artisan level where people
are indicating that coming from this
sort of artisan background is as
appropriate something you're proud of
they are happy to pass on to their
children
so one of the ways you can look at a
ranking of of these of this level of
artisan skill or a proto industrial
skill is to look at at surnames if you
look at in the 2000 census the United
States Smith is the most common surname
in the United States and Miller is the
seventh most common surname after that
you go down to 13 in order to get to
Taylor 34 to get to write 38 to get to
Baker
so Miller and Smith are the most common
occupational names that we have a
surnames in this country that's in 2000
you know the Miller is ranked number
seven if you then go and you look at the
names of European immigrant groups
you'll find that there is a similar
parallel that in German German families
in this country
Schmidt is ranked 171 Miller is ranked
1198 the Dutch Smith and Mulder or even
though the molder was a Miller x-files
guy Ferraro versus Molinaro in Italian
for our Molinari an Italian Herrera
versus Molina in Spanish Lefevre versus
mini a and French Kuznetsov versus
Melnick and Russian Kovich in
Miller in Hungarian the reason I I did a
calculation of this because I was struck
by the fact that there are no Arab
Miller's so I looked at where does Smith
show up among surnames the United States
or the Arabic version of Smith Hadad
Hadad Hadad depending on how you want to
pronounce it well it's it's not real
high because we don't have that large
and Arab population let's rank three
thousand among surnames in 2000 as for
the surname the Arabic version of the
surname Miller which is tahan that shows
up at fifty thousand and the there are
only two or three families in the
country that that have the surname to
Han and most of them apparently are
Sephardic Jews from Spain not from the
Middle East so so this is that were
there no Millers in the Middle East does
was there an absence of the social
formation that contributed so strongly
to the growth of industry in Europe in
other words if you have an idea who
makes that idea happen who makes it real
I would say that it was the Smiths and
the Millers who played very important
roles here but you had no Miller's
showing up at this level in in the
Middle East or North Africa in the Arab
world that's why I'm checking on here
you'll Persian and Turkish surnames are
not normal before 1900s so you can't
easily transfer it there but the Arabic
and the the Arabic is common now
we know that the per capita consumption
of grain in the middle east of North
Africa was roughly equivalent to per
capita consumption of grain in Europe so
they must have been milling grain at
roughly the same per capita rate in Arab
countries as they were in Europe but
nobody gets called a Miller you think
well why is that
and the answer appears to be that the
the Miller's the mills that you have the
people who ground grain but by the way
too
technically we have evidence that
sawmills paper mills that the things you
could do with the mill all existed in
the medieval Middle East at least as
early as they existed in in Europe so it
wasn't a matter of a lack of ingenuity
of how to hook up a mill to some
industrial process what was a matter of
scale a mill in the Middle East North
Africa was typically operated by a an ox
or a camel or a donkey that you have a a
millstone you own an arm that stuck off
the millstone you attached your animal
to the arm and you had to go around and
around and around and around and around
until it dropped down and then you
bought a new animal there was no way you
could scale that up from Morocco all the
way across to Afghanistan industrial
processes that require power use animal
power and animal power was incredibly
cheap because this were these were lands
that were semi-arid or desert and the
animals were raised with virtually no
cost by pastoral nomads so you'd have to
pay money to replace the animal but the
animal the extremely cheap
nomads were not depending upon selling
of animals for their livelihood because
their their wealth was determined by
ownership of the animals not by the sale
of the animals nor did the nomads
particularly want to accumulate a lot of
goods if you have a sack of gold then
you have to carry a sack of gold round
with you and gold is heavy so so you did
not have the profit Nexus that was
making your animal power expensive and
in fact the animal power was very cheap
so there was no impetus to develop a
watermill system that would be a large
fixed installation that would cost a
great deal of investment in order to
have as your basis for for harnessing
water power
the factories that were built during the
industrial revolution we're called mills
that is not a trivial attribute trivial
observation a factory if you go back to
the 1500s 1600s a factory factory was a
word that applied to a overseas trading
outpost of one of these European trading
trading companies factory was not a
place of manufacturing it was a place
where a factor who would be the the
in-country operative of the business
would do his work a what we would call a
factory they called a mill a cotton mill
sawmill whatever the reason I called it
a mill was because that's how they
started the people who were most
involved in many of these factories were
people who had backgrounds coming from
the harnessing of water power steam
develops I would suggest them in
substantial part because you had
Miller's you didn't have steamers no
steamer never shows up as a last name
boiler maker not very common unless
you're a graduate of Purdue rather other
Boilermakers there isn't any very
obvious surname that is related to to to
steam because the unless somebody can
think of one because the people who were
had the knowledge of how to harness the
power of steam were people who had
already developed that skill in
harnessing the power of running water
they know the gears
they knew transmission belts they knew
how to hook up
mechanical devices that would do all
sorts of things and I think that that
the non-existence of Miller's in the
Arab world made the progress of steam
they're almost non-existent because you
didn't have the the right class of
people to to make it happen at a at a
functional level
I don't know whether this is whether
this is true or not
it's a conjecture of my part but what it
leads to is the idea that it isn't the
investor necessarily or the inventor or
the the person who who owns the
operation but does not actually operate
it who is important or the scientist who
had an insight that later pays off in
some sense but I think that the social
element that is crucial here is a
mid-level non-noble artisan based social
stratum that is skilled in particular
types of operations that can be scaled
up and diversified in in useful ways or
that provide the capital that allow them
to finance other operations because once
they have money what are they going to
do with the money if they can't exchange
it for some dramatic increase in their
social rank so in Japan and Saki Brewers
in China its salt merchants in Europe
it's it's who I would suggest the
Millers and the Smiths as being key
figures here this all relates to a
historiographical question of whether
you when you look at when you look at a
period of change what is it
let's say I'm a socialist story more
than intellectual historian what is it
you look at you look at the inventor or
do you look at the investor do you look
at the the scientist who had the insight
so if you take say a personal computer
do you say well who won the Nobel Prize
for invent for inventing the transistor
it was not the guy who invented the
personal computer you know where did the
money come from for Apple to get started
well we don't really care much about who
the investors were nor was there
particularly an invention there those
things that were distinctive about the
Macintosh had already been invented and
put into use by the Xerox Corporation no
the mouse and the icons and so forth and
so on what Steve Jobs and his colleagues
do is take off the shelf ideas and make
them happen and what Steve Gates and his
colleagues do is that they take
off-the-shelf ideas and make them happen
less well but but in many many
industries it's really that that dirty
hands stratum of people who know how to
to actually put things together and
think about how to scale them up how to
market them and so forth and so on
but that's that's the stratum that that
makes things happen I've been thinking
for some time about collecting indicate
collecting instances of important
inventions that did not work until there
was a second invention and saying well
what is the you know is there a class of
inventions that are facilitating
invention
thing wouldn't work until you have a
second invention of some sort and then
who who invented that so it's usually
the inventor who gets the credit and
somebody else often somebody working for
the inventor who makes it makes it work
Alexander Graham Bell invented the
telephone which did not work in the way
that we think of the telephone working
because you could not carry on you did
not want to carry on a conversation on a
telephone you had a device it had a wire
it went to a central office and you
could talk to the central office and
they could talk to you if you were
having a dinner party they could have a
string quartet at the central office and
play music and you could pick up your
telephone and you would have piped music
into your dining room I was actually an
early service of the telephone industry
you could have it so that if there was a
news report your phone would ring and
you'd pick it up and the person in the
central would say you know Archduke
Ferdinand was just killed or something
like that but you couldn't talk to
another telephone you could only talk to
the central telephone because the switch
hadn't been invented
so somebody working for Bell invents the
switch that allows you to have to have
subscriber a talk to subscriber B by
going to the center plugging in a plug
and hooking up with the other subscriber
that wasn't Bell but without that we
don't have a telephone we don't know the
telephone the universal product code the
barcode that was invented Oh 50 60 years
ago I don't remember exactly when it was
originally a bull's-eye sort of thing
with different thicknesses for the
concentric circles
and you could read it by shining a light
on it they would reflect back and you
would you could put all the numerical
information that we have on a product
code now would show up them and it it
worked but it turned out that in order
to get it to reflect you had to have a
light bulb of such high candle power
that it generated enormous heat so you
couldn't put it in the supermarket
because you were going to toast the the
products if you put them in front of the
of this thing and your checkout person
was going to be you know sweating
buckets all day long because they're in
a high temperature environment so you
could use it to sort railway cars where
you know you didn't have a closed
environment but it turned out that it
was the the facilitating invention was
the cheap transistor so that you are the
cheap laser rather so that when you had
a cheap laser that developed no general
heat then you could have the universal
product code so I think that historians
of science are sometimes become obsessed
with the the intellectual breakthrough
of a scientific discovery or the
formation of a scientific law but if
you're looking at how it how the economy
changes and how the society changes I
think that you really need to look at a
different social stratum and then in a
way Europe was was lucky because it had
the enormous expansion of a stratum of
Miller's coming out of the late Middle
Ages that gave them a population that
was capable of capitalizing on and
commercializing ideas that may have come
from various other sources so the
Industrial Revolution
uh clearly there is a change in the
outlook and I would suggest that that
there's a change in the social status of
people who are making these industrial
advances that they are becoming
important in a way that is much that
sort of scaling up from the importance
they had before in the novel by Sterling
and Gibson I mentioned you have the in
addition to the the Lord spiritual set
in the House of Lords or the the Lord's
temporal who hold land you have the what
the Lord scientific who are noble and
doubled by the contributions to science
that's a fat chance
so maybe I'm just seeking here for my
prejudice a social historian I think
what we need to look at in these periods
of change there's much more the various
social components of it rather than
looking simply at what happens in a
scientific or a technological sense